en el Reino Unido el Primer Ministro
Richie sunaks endurece las leyes
migratorias
nos permitirá detener a los barcos que
están trayendo decenas de miles de
personas a nuestras costas en flagrante
violación tanto de nuestras leyes como
de la voluntad del pueblo británico
no dejarán de venir Hasta que el mundo
sepa que si entras ilegalmente en el
Reino Unido serás detenido y rápidamente
expulsado
expulsados a terceros países como Ruanda
además no podrán pedir refugio un plan
considerado ineficaz e inhumano por los
activistas de los Derechos en muy poco
probable que esta nueva legislación
repercuta en el número de personas que
intentan llegar a Reino Unido en busca
de protección Esto se debe a que
simplemente no hay otras rutas hacia
Reino Unido el gobierno debería
centrarse en crear rutas seguras para
que la gente pueda llegar a Reino Unido
y también en crear un sistema de asilo
que funcione en el que la solicitudes se
transmiten a tiempo cada semana decenas
de personas arriesgan su vida para
cruzar el Canal de la Mancha y llegar al
Reino Unido según las organizaciones
decenas de miles de refugiados a los que
se podría conceder asilo corren ahora el
riesgo de ser tratados como criminales
lo que incumpliría con la convención de
la ONU sobre los refugiados de la que el
Reino Unido hace parte esta convención
permite a los solicitantes de asilo
recibir un juicio justo
independientemente de como hayan llegado
a un país tras un brexit que promete
recuperar el control de las fronteras
Richie sunaka ha hecho de la detención
de las llegadas de los migrantes una de
sus cinco principales prioridades